good morning Millennials I didn't want
to say it because I knew you're were GNA
come for me no I wouldn't I came for I
only needed to say it once and we
established your good morning
Millennials way of doing GMM thank you
but good morning to all our Millennials
out there Jen
XYZ Boomers Boomers of course what's
before
Boomers I think I read something
recently I could 100% be making this up
but have you heard of Zoomers yeah
what's that I think it's under Boomers
right under as an older than Boomers no
younger okay who's older than
Boomers no I I don't think there is I
think they're at the top of the Heap
okay well welcome everyone to our show
happy Monday the Monday after
Thanksgiving weekend what a joyous we
holiday weekend we can't ask for
anything more than totally a beautiful
holiday weekend
plus we have a very exciting episode
today because trout skin is co-hosting
with me today I'm here trout skin is
Olivia our older sister because Claudia
is out doing du Ting this morning today
is a very big day for due and his
recovery so we are all sending prayers
up for du I have my D pillow if you're
watching on YouTube um I think I'll just
like leave it here yes I love that just
so that everyone can be reminded of the
power of du and how D needs our thoughts
and prayers at this moment agreed agreed
prayers for Theo we're do strong always
yeah so hopefully cud would back to
tomorrow and we'll know a little bit
more but today Olivia is joining us to
do the toast which is always a delight
thank you so much for having me you know
I absolutely love being here and I will
say every time I do the show which is
you know rare um it's more frequent
these days it's more frequent these days
but that's what I was going to say is
like I have more and more like my level
of respect for you and Claudia is
astronomical but it gets even higher
because the way that I pick myself apart
like watching myself like I don't
understand how you do it you can't watch
like and then all everybody gives you
like feedback you know put some bronzer
in your part Olivia don't wear this
makeup don't this don't that and so like
you know I I feel like today I came
ready you know to like punch out the
comments you know okay you don't have to
read the comments and you don't have to
watch it back no but by the way
sometimes people's feedback is really
helpful like you don't can't always like
see yourself like I can't see myself
right now so you know I don't know how
I'm looking and then afterwards people
give you feedback okay if you have to
through a bunch of crap to find like one
helpful comment is it that helpful
totally totally yeah know like my foot
is covered so people don't say anything
about feet they love to come for the raw
dog I just I was really all like
prepared like I'm ready to go come at me
yeah my I don't I usually wear like a
shoe on the show but sometimes my
Instagram story like I guess a Barefoot
will make it into the frame and the way
people go buck wild when they a Barefoot
it's like are you guys okay and also
like everybody has feet you know it's so
weird and I think my hands are worse
than my feet so no and I don't have like
bad feet or it's just the concept of
like seeing feet yeah positively some
people you know are a little too here
for it other people are like put those
feet away it's like it's just my feet
it's just my feet yeah well we're
matching today we are matching we did
not coordinate we're just so sympatico
did yeah we are and how are you doing
since we last saw you I'm doing good we
had um such a lovely weekend of just
like kid Centric family fun and that was
such a high um and then obviously there
are you know the emotional complexities
with what's going on in the world and
like so thankful thank Hashem that you
know hostages are coming home but also
just the turmoil around it's not quick
enough and it's not in the way that was
agreed upon which was already a shitty
agreement if we're going to be real
about it like one innocent child hostage
for three convicted attempted murderers
is just not really Apples to Apples and
then they're you know delaying hostage
release Red Cross still hasn't visited
but we have gotten um I think it was
like 13 hostages for the last three days
today there should be a hostage release
probably while we're recording so um
just praying that everyone comes home
yeah it's like so emotionally complex
like the highs and lows of like waiting
hoping being so happy for the ones who
are out and just like being so
heartbroken for the ones who are in and
even like you know they're supposed to
release children and their mothers
yesterday a girl came out who was with
her mom in captivity the entire time and
then they separated them 2 days before
she came out and said and then the mom
didn't come out but like that's not the
agreement right so it's just really
frustrating but I guess that's what
happens like when you're trying to make
an agreement with an actual terrorist
organization like you can't really trust
that they're going to be the most
forthcoming totally totally so yeah just
yeah that's definitely added um a a
layer a layer to the weekend but
otherwise it was a very very lovely
holiday weekend we had Thanksgiving
Olivia made a really amazing turkey
proba best you hosted so beautifully we
had such a nice time we had such a nice
time but probably I always like turkey
I'm not one of those people that's like
turkey turkey you know like dry I think
that's Claudia is like turkeyy gross
like no it's not it's totally fine the
kids we told the kids it was chicken we
didn't have to tell them they picked it
up and ate it they said chicken yum like
it's chicken
okay I think it's poultry right like is
a yeah like if you look at a turkey bird
and like when they're alive and and a
chicken Bird yeah they look alike they
do they do a turkey is definitely they
the they're of the same elk yeah yeah
yeah totally um but Olivia made a really
really amazing turkey probably the best
that I've ever had and I'm not someone
who like complains about turkey is what
I was trying to say so I appreciate that
can you tell everyone what you did I
totally can um so this is my second time
ever making a turkey the first year I
followed the Half Bake Harvest turkey
recipe it's the one that's most
recommended and honestly my turkey last
year was really good um but I my like
content that I am served is so diverse
and I would say like 60% of what I was
being served up was Turkey related in
the last um you know couple weeks and so
I really wanted to give like spatch
cocking turkey a try I just like kept
seeing it everywhere and everybody like
makes it look so easy to cut out the
backbone I'm here to tell you that it's
actually like not that easy I was
sweating like you wouldn't believe like
I bought a 16 lb turkey in a lot of the
videos that I saw and things that I
looked up online was like 10 to 12 or 10
to 15 so like I knew I had a big bird
you know um but I did wind up getting it
and you like crack the breast bone down
but essentially you you create a flat
turkey so that it can evenly cook and it
cooks faster and so I didn't follow a
recipe I just kind of made this like
Herby roasted garlic paste so I did like
parsley thy used my time trick don't
forget it um two bulbs of roasted garlic
and then like salt pepper olive oil and
I just like rubbed it all over put it in
the pan with some you know aromatics at
the bottom celery carrots onion lemon
garlic and it cooked for 2 hours and it
really was like unbelievable and also I
feel like what I did would be good
really with like any meat like I can't
wait to do that with a chicken yeah use
the leftovers with my leftover gravy to
make turkey pot pie the next night which
was also Stellar um cuz by the way we
had a lot of turkey left over hence the
16 lb turkey and and I have no more
turkey left in my house like I'm
completely out oh I need to check my
fridge I only had leftovers on Friday
and then I didn't engage I feel like
that's normal even for you to even have
leftovers in the first place is like a
big deal yeah I'm not a huge leftovers
person but Thanksgiving food like I
think it translates nicely to leftovers
but I do I think today's the day where I
officially throw away anything that
hasn't been that's fair I think that's
absolutely Fair yeah and Jackie hosted
be your table was so colorful and bright
and lovely we had delicious food
delicious conversation the kids had such
a nice time it was so fun I was saying I
was so burned out from the day like we
did a whole episode on patreon of
Thanksgiving table topics like you know
stories that are going on in the world
like I don't think I said one word at
the table I was so
like no I don't even know what we talked
about our conversation was so light and
Airy like we had a lovely time we didn't
like have conversation we really just
like talked about the food I was going
to say I feel like that's what we talk
about a lot when we're like sitting at T
de Mia like we talk about the food we're
eating or other food I don't feel like
always but certainly like we all cooked
all day like let's all talk about what's
good on the table like what needs what
what we would make again yeah that's the
conversation also what we ate last year
versus this year like we were talking
about food the whole time right but it's
also not like we ate for that long no I
think we ate pretty you also made like
spinach Artic choke dip like you made
lovely things yeah and I um no but like
the the sitting down wasn't very long
for e no and it never is like you cook
all day for a 20 minute meal that's
always how it goes yeah so it wasn't
like that much conversation to be had
and we were like both tired so it was
just so dead it wasn't like you know I
couldn't have possibly been as tired as
you though because like you did I made
the turkey but like you did everything
else yeah I was just um like I was doing
fine and then I just like was so broken
you were on your feet all day that's
what my husband said on Friday on Friday
he played 33 holes of golf and on Friday
night he's like I'm so tired I was on my
feet all day I'm like how can he like
that's not okay to say right but that's
like that's elective on your feet yeah I
wanted to also tell you what your per
last night cuz I feel like everyone
would get like such a riot out of this
but um you know people wake up in the
middle of the night like they go to the
bathroom or whatnot and my husband's
making so much noise in the middle of
the night this is like partially why I'm
so tired today I was just like what the
[__] are you doing he's like I just took
a shower it must have been 3: in the
morning I don't even know what time it
was I'm like what's wrong with you he's
like I definitely have lice I'm like
what he's like I'm so itchy we've all
been there I'm like okay first of all
you would be like the last person in the
house to get like
it nobody's that hasn't crossed anyone's
mind I'm like you probably like have
aurn on your head and it's itchy or like
maybe you're having allergic reaction
cuz he has like so many allergic
reactions I was just like you're being
nuts go back to sleep and I roll over
and I don't know what time it was I want
to say it was like 3:00 a.m. he's
[__] scrolling on his phone I'm like
put your phone down and go to sleep cuz
he's like the type of person if he feels
like he's up he's up and I'm like uh-uh
like we are going back to sleep that
light is not going to keep me up you are
being insane goodai so I'm also tired
today so does he have lice absolutely
not then a lice check I did actually
this morning and I was like your head is
your scalp is red like you have either
some sort of like
reaction the itching of it yeah the
itching of it he also has dandruff like
get a new shampoo like do not take
shower in the middle of the night and
wake me up I know but we've all sort of
been there where you're just like I
think I have lice
today what if I just had the thing about
lice is like the the second someone says
the word lice I can guarantee you for
anybody watching the show you're going
to start it your [__] yeah yeah I
wonder if my husband has ever had lice
I've never asked him I don't know if my
husband actually has ever had I just
think he immediately went there we had
like a million times I mean we're like
girls we went to camp we have a lot of
hair I feel like we actually evaded it
for so long and then we got it like kind
of late in life for and then we got it
over and over and over again and it's
not like something that like once you
get once you're more susceptible to but
I had lice became lice scarly school
like I I was in the nth grade when I had
lice for sure um I like vividly remember
that but that like makes sense because
like Margot would have been in like the
third grade and that would be a time to
get lice and she would have given it to
me you know yeah I love how we're just
slandering her saying like she gave me
lce or I it could have been from
anywhere else but Margot you definitely
gave it to me that time I feel like for
as many times as we had it everyone
played their part I don't remember ever
giving it yeah sure sure sure sure it's
actually like I just get it lice like
loves like clean hair clean people so
it's like kind of like such a compliment
when you get they say I think that's one
of those like kid tricks you know where
oh no no I think it's genuine like they
want like a nice clean surface to like
you know amplify their sure their eggs
but say ace makes it into the head of a
dirty you know complicated hair are they
leaving are they packing their bags or
they're just maybe they're not spreading
as fast I don't know they're just like
unhappily residing I think it's one of
those things to tell kids it's like oh
they picked you because you're so clean
and your hair is
amazing that's why it happened to you
that's like a good go right to cheer up
kids yeah yeah sure sure sure um okay
well we have a very jolly good show for
you today some great stories some great
advertisements and we have a trout skin
here so you just never know where things
are going to go when never know I feel
like we keep it on the path you know we
we actually do I think Claud and I I
think are the worst combination but and
the best of like tangents but that's
also that's the point that's the nature
of the show Point 100% with guests you
know it's easier to stay on track yeah
totally so I consider myself like I'm
I'm not a guest in the traditional sense
you know co-host guest co-host yeah yeah
yeah are you not that no but I'm not
like a Bravo star you know oh no but
guest
co-host like Ben is a guest co-host too
yeah yeah yeah yeah I just feel like Ben
me Maro are in like one category of
people and then there are like other
famous people that are in another
category gu co-host okay where would you
put like Taylor shreer cuz she's also
like family that's so hard why would you
do that to me I'm just trying to like
make a it out I was just trying to
compare myself to like a page tooro like
we're not the same you know okay like
she's a queen you know you're a queen no
in a different way a queen of a
different Kingdom yeah 100% okay cool
well we have a great show also did you
see the conversation um last week
Claudia was like pressing you roasted
for something I'm always getting roasted
but like sports oh yeah what' you say
what' you do oh I said um you'll like
this I CU honestly the last time I was
on here talking about sports like I
definitely got a few things wrong again
and I got some positive feedback that I
learned stuff you know yeah so what I
said was you know the Eagles and the
chiefs were playing each other last week
and I said It felt thirsty right and
that it's what I said that was
inaccurate was that I said it doesn't
count towards anything it's kind of like
a showcase
scrimmage but what but I was right in
the sense that there are two teams that
wouldn't ORD they're not in the same
conference so it was like they were
chosen by the NFL to play but they were
chosen because often times the Super
Bowl teams do play each other next year
and that game does count towards their
score right so I was wrong about it
being a scrimmage no of course and it
was scheduled before Taylor Swift
entered the picture so it wasn't thirsty
on that count but it did still feel
thirsty because of Kelsey bowl no
totally there's a lot of things in the
NFL that are just they really do feel
too scripted like tell me how all of a
sudden the Dolphins like were playing
you know in New York so that Braxton
could be with Alex Earl's family for
Thanksgiving and her whole family could
go to the game my gosh I was wondering
how he was with her for Thanksgiving
when he had a game on Friday because he
was down the street that's how like
there's just so many things and by the
way like it just it feels it does feel
scripted no that's I thought he like
flew in flew out I was wondering that I
forgot to like follow up and I didn't
realize they were playing in New York
yeah I think CLA was at the game she was
at the game no that makes complete sense
and then her whole family went to the
game yeah which is actually like lovely
like it's very sweet it's just like how
did he play a TBD I don't know I saw one
play that like didn't look good for him
he was chasing after some I think the
Dolphins like had an amazing game like
they had a like 99 yard touchdown where
like the ball was thrown and they
intercepted it and ran all the way back
so I think it was a huge team win yeah
they won the game yeah the Jets terrible
Aaron Rogers of it all yeah so okay who
like that's a celebration and then Aaron
Rogers apparently got cleared right
after the game to like be able to come
back I think he's playing this week or
something like that again don't come for
me I don't know but he said he was going
to be back by December he's back I think
he's ready for action love that for him
I've missed him I'd rather see him out
there shaking that
thing so yeah there were a lot of
scripted Thanksgiving football and you
know that's like I didn't know that that
was a running joke with in the NFL did
you see um there was a sketch I don't
know what it was for now that maybe it
was for like opening football season it
was like a sketch about how the NFL is
scripted by the NFL and it was all of
them sitting around a table about like
things that they were going to do this
year fun no because it's like there's
too many things that are just to because
that's what say scripted yeah
huh huh the more you now any other
sports this weekend Eagles won they're
doing well happy for them yeah we like
we Cowboys won on Thanksgiving
yes yeah that's always a big game for
you yeah yeah yeah so I was happy and
Harry's a little Cowboys fan he is yeah
so I was happy for my boys yeah and
that's your sports
recap love it 100% accurate all the
facts right here did you buy anything
for Black Friday I did I was telling
everyone I think I said this on the
patreon I don't know if I said it on the
show I I got my outdoor furniture oh yes
I'm so excited for you mostly because
I'm excited for myself I'm so excited
like it's been a while since I've been
excited about like a big purchase I
guess cuz I haven't bought Furniture in
a while um and now I'm like reupping and
I'm I just like can't I'm counting down
the days yeah I can't wait for next
summer I'm counting the days well it's
summer here all the time so you're good
it's from the book I know oh my God I'm
the book camper and counselor um never
heard of it did you get anything for
Black Friday I did um I bought a new
fridge for my garage because um my
current fridge in my garage is like from
the house when we bought it and I just
like wanted to get like a new one and
just upgrade it and I just felt like
Black Friday was a perfect purchase yeah
that's the perfect thing to get um and
then I just bought the kids a bunch of
stuff I bought them a bunch of clothes
from like memes and Amazon and all the
different places um I think my husband
like he got a lot of shoes from God
knows where there's always packages
showing up at my door yeah same um I got
my um white elephant gift sacred Santa
sacred Santa Santa I like sacred Santa
yeah I got I thought like Black Friday
was the perfect time to buy it somebody
did remind me to do that I think it was
Claudia Claudia I got my sacred Santa
gift too did you I'm so eager to know
who you have I'm eager to know who you
have I bet you are kiding no it's not
it's me I swear I swear it's not oh my
God I'm you're the worst person to buy
for I just bought you for your birthday
you know so I feel like I'm glad to be
done with you easiest person to buy for
like when I've been shopping for other
people I'm like this would be great for
me this that wear bracelet that I got
you though so I did I am wearing
Olivia's birthday gift she got me an
evil eye bracelet it's working [__]
tata for
now oh my God I'm
crying so sacred Santa I feel like the
whole of the toast is so invested in our
secret santa I can't wait we are going
to have to patreon yeah we've been
talking about it Claudia and I on the
show did you tell Zach Shapiro your
husband who you have yes you told him
like immediately right I was just like
should we tell each other what who we
have and he was like yeah and honest ly
like I'm really glad that I did you know
oh okay I know who who he has then no no
no I'm saying like for me like I needed
help oh you need oh so it wasn't me yeah
and then for him it's not you but for
him I I also
like I maybe helped him a little too no
that's the point of tell of you like I
Zach and I told each other so that um
yeah we could help he had a really good
idea your husband is amazing at like gab
gifts finding like things that nobody's
ever heard of that are the best things
in the world like that's his special
this his specialty like a like $100 cap
I was like saying that I actually like
hope he has me because like I feel like
he would get a great gift you know is
there anything that you want that you
want to put forth to your sacred Santa
no but are you saying that he has me no
he doesn't watch this
show no I honestly I want for nothing
and that's why I feel like I'm
personally a hard person to buy for like
I have everything I want like I don't
need anything you know um but I just
like would be eager to see what somebody
would need you know think I want or need
yeah you could always get a little crap
from Etsy always yeah I mean I have tons
of crap and I love it yeah I love
crap okay let's get into the stories no
more Dilly dallying without further Ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you you need to know as we pray for
you today wow that was excellent thank
you I always like to put a little
something special for the day on you're
clever thank you Olivia can I take a sip
of your coffee will you kill me wow bra
that's why you complimented me
that's why she complimented me the way
that that thought process didn't even
cross my mind is this the M special
that's the M special taste it it tastes
really good you guys there's a place
called the cheese stores in Florida and
Long Island and they have the best iced
coffee and Margot our sister and Emily
her best friend made a special flavor
it's called the M special I'm sure
you've been seeing them posting about it
it's sold out already oh okay so get a
different flavor from The Cheese Store
my personal favorite is Oreo and vanilla
velvet yeah you got me on to Oreo I
usually do hazelnut it's just tried and
true but I've been enjoying I saw
s'mores from your house on Thanksgiving
it was really good it's for you uh I
know always drops off for both of us and
I never give it to you I know that's why
I stole it when I was like helping put
food away because I was like this I feel
like belongs to me I took a bottle yay
big literally does belong to you so
enjoy today's episode is brought to you
by hatch I love hatch we are a hatch
family and if you don't know about hatch
yet let me tell you shall I count the
ways hatch is the best best product for
falling asleep staying asleep and waking
up it makes waking up so Humane it makes
going to sleep so calming relaxing
peaceful and you need to get your hatch
so hatch being today's Sor is so
appropriate because this morning I woke
up 5 minutes before my alarm sound went
off and waking up to a sunrise at my
hatch rest store instead of my phone
alarm put me in such a good mood and
made it so much easier to jump start my
day yes hatch slowly wakes you up with
the sun it takes like 30 minutes it
starts getting lighter and lighter until
your alarm goes off but often times you
wake up before your alarm and isn't that
the best feeling in the world totally so
great sleep can be earned with hatch 83%
of customers report improved sleep
improved that's what I was trying to say
and they have a 60 night money back
guarantee so you can try it for yourself
risk-free the hatch restore is a device
that helps you build a consistent
bedtime and morning routine so you can
prioritize rest and sleep better also
I'm personally I unlocked all of the uh
noise machine features and I love it
because they have so many different
noises to choose from I'm personally in
like a night uh rainstorm love that
state of mind but you can do it on your
phone so if I'm like across the room and
like I'm nap trapped and I want to turn
the sound machine on cuz Charlie fell
asleep like I can just do it on my phone
and it will come on and I don't have to
go turn it on across the room but you
can also tap it on top it's just an
amazing device you're obsessed I'm
obsessed I could go on and on right now
hatch is offering our listeners $20 off
your first your purchase of the Hatcher
store and free shipping at hatch. co/
toast that's hatch. co/ toast to get $20
off and free shipping hatch. co/ toast
you guys $20 off it's the best also
today's episode is brought to you by
caroway and honestly this weekend was
brought to you by caroway because
Thanksgiving was brought to you by
carway in my household there is a gift
for everyone from car from caroway so
this holiday season you could be buying
for anyone honestly like if you had a
sister for secret santa who loves to
cook I would you know suggest carow way
for that person it's non-toxic easy
cooking well-loved and gorgeous also
this was the weekend of carway for me
because I finally got my pink my set of
monochromatic pink pots and pans from
the tan friends collection I've been
talking about eyeing them on the show
and then caroway sent me them for my
birthday and I'm just it was the best
gift that's so nice after my evil I bra
yeah obviously Namaste [__] and
everything my friends and family bought
me then
carway so it's time to make it official
and be the family favorite by gifting
carway the holidays are closer than ever
so make sure you order by December 15th
to get their gift or yours underneath
the tree in time yeah also carway is a
great self gift like give yourself the
gift of easier dishes give yourself the
gift of tastier food give yourself the
gift of a gorgeous Kitchen where you can
leave where you can leave your pots on
top of the stove and it looks nice yeah
so visit carway home.com the toast to
take advantage of this limited time
offer for up to 20% off your next
purchase this deal is ex exclusive for
our listeners and won't last long so
visit carway home.com theeast to get new
kitchen wear before the holidays Caraway
non-toxic cookware made Modern today's
episode is also brought to you by well
well is one of those products I'm
actually wearing on the toast right now
because it's in my hair last night I
washed my hair and well is the best
postwash product and you absolutely need
it so well professionals has over 140
years of experience developed initially
for professional use only and previously
only sold in salons and consistently
ranked among the top most loved Brands
by professional stylists the ultimate
repair Miracle Hair rescue that's what I
have in my hair right now what I've been
using every time I wash my hair it's a
leave-in spray treatment designed to
work on wet hair so it's going to repair
your hair it's going to do everything it
needs to do and it also smells so good
so I don't have to worry about like my
shampoo or conditioner smelling good
because like the well is what's going to
make my hair smell good for as long as
it's unwashed which for me is four to 5
days I'm not going to lie so with key
ingredients Aha and Omega 9 you can
rebuild the hair bonds inside the
strands and replenish the outside
barrier of damaged hair their bonding
[__] repairs hair damage in 90 seconds so
Well's new line ultimate repair is the
most premium line to date and it was
developed with 140 plus years of
experience so that's a lot of history
you and me got a whole lot of
history do you know this song One
Direction oh my God yeah I was like do
you think I'm just singing Nonsense no I
know you so here's how I use it after I
get out of the shower I just spray the
ultimate repair Miracle Hair rescue as
many times as needed they recommend 5 to
10 pumps go a little crazy whatever and
then you wait 90 seconds before styling
I style my hair in the morning so it's
sitting there all night and I have
gorgeous thick hair in the morning
gorgeous hair thank you you can try the
ultimate repair Miracle Hair rescue with
10% off the travel size on Amazon by
using promo code 10 toast now let's get
into the sto just one more PSA a PSA
from trouty a sprit Society 35% off
sitewide last day I'm pretty sure I
heard through the rumor mill that pink
lemonade is basically selling out today
if it's not already sold out so again
pink lemonade is what you're saying yeah
and 40% off the new bundles tropical
Trio and lemonade Stam which also has
pink lemonade in it which is another way
to get it but last day 35% off biggest
sale they've ever done sprits
society.com s p r i TZ
society.com our first story some happy
baby news and the kind of shocking
thankful Paris Hilton secretly welcomes
a second baby with her husband Carter
room and reveals the name so she's
officially a family of four Paris
revealed on Friday that her and her
husband Carter secretly welcomed their
second baby she posted a picture of a
pink outfit monogram with the name
London and said thankful for my baby
girl so um in multiple videos she called
her son Phoenix a big brother and gush
to her nieces and neews about having to
babies I like I saw this I thought she
was it was an announcement of a
pregnancy yeah and then you told me that
no like the baby is here which is so
amazing that's two successful secret
pregnancies for her which I think is
like the hardest thing to do and her
kids are like 11 months apart amazing
yeah I also love that like obviously her
name is Paris her son is Phoenix her
daughter's London like she went with
like the city thematic naming convention
I know I wish we had the opportunity to
guess what her baby name would be
because I think like would have been
able to guess it I incorrectly guessed
for her son I thought his name was going
to be maximilan oh no I don't see that
for her maximilan room Hilton I really
felt Hilton room I really felt like that
was going to be it okay well you were
wrong well she likes the cities but so
if we had to do girl city names yeah
London would be top or Sydney it's also
funny cuz London Tipton from Sweet Life
of Zack and Cody is based off of Paris
Hilton right and life imitates art she
named her daughter London so now we
really have a London Hilton Room London
Hilton room yeah we have a room at the
Hilton I'm actually so happy for her I'm
so happy for her and she had spoken
about how she really wants a daughter um
I think after her son was born and just
in general maybe it was even in her book
that I read but um yeah I do love this
era for her like in her life you know I
love it for her she's like a
businesswoman she's a DJ she's a wife
she's a mom she's doing her thing and
she takes Phoenix everywhere with her
and they're just like such a cute family
unit so I'm really excited that she is
growing her family and to have two kids
so close in age it's just so wonderful
so wonderful totally I'm so happy for
her also speaking of celebrity Memoirs
Britney Spears the woman in me is a
redheads book this month did you know
that I did cuz we talked about it last
time I was on and I said I was going to
read it and I haven't yet but I still
will wow I need to find more things to
share but um that's just a reminder that
you should be com a redhead it's never
too late uh the first Thursday of De
mber so next Thursday and we're
recording next week so I haven't started
the book yet but another book update I'm
getting through iron flame like I'm I'm
almost there to get through I don't
really understand what's going on do you
know what iron flame is no okay have you
heard of fourth wi I've I've seen y'all
post things you know the new ya series
it's very Hunger Games okay so for Vi
but cool was like a huge success we read
it for the redheads me Claudia and Margo
loved it and then the new book The the
sequel just came out and like Claud and
I been struggling to get through it not
cuz it's bad it's just like slow and
long and verbose but now I think I'm at
like 70% like hopefully I finish it
today it's good it's just it that took
too long understood understood but it's
also me like I'm having a hard time like
reading for chunks of periods of time
but that's why I was able to read this
weekend which was really nice that is
lovely so we'll have a little fourth a
little iron flame recap on the redheads
episode this month right cuz you're all
reading it except for Dana because she
would never she did not like the first
oh okay yeah I love Dana going against
the Green Oh you need to listen to the
redheads that's all she does she hates
everything cuz she's so highbrow that's
so interesting though because like in
real life like Dana is the most amable
person on Earth it's like oh you want to
do this yeah sure like she never is
contrarian no when it comes to books
like that's her thing oh okay Dana learn
something new about she's our harshest
critic oh okay her but also snitch
because like the books that Dana but I
expect that from snitch that's her
that's like that Dana would like you
know not to say snitch's low brow no
they're just different different brows
yeah different brows left brow right
brow we could say unibrow they're not
unibrow and that's the problem yeah 100%
but then with Rebecca and me in the
middle we make a unibrow but Becky feels
like somebody like Becky's very she has
that similar vibe to Dana where they're
just like super go with the flow like
down for anything so I can kind of see
her being that person she's strong
opinions honestly I'm the one who's like
it was good oh really yeah I don't
expect that of you I know I just like I
feel bad
trashing a book like when not trashing
but like I always kind of reel in what
I'm saying just because like someone
worked so hard on this and like if I
finish the book unless it was a absolute
piece of garbage my country friends like
there's it's like there's something to
discuss if someone liked it you know
yeah yeah for sure plus it's my job as
the host of the show to like be a little
more impartial I find that's really
where I you're moderating the
conversation I do moderate yes so happy
for the Hilton room family yeah me too
and what do you think they'll have
another kid I know that's inappropriate
to ask but I'm just going to you know
pose the question oh I hate when people
ask it to me I'm not pregnant but I do
hope to have another kid okay thank you
um I I don't know what I wouldn't be
surprised if they don't like some people
feel really strongly like they're when
they're at two they're like I'm done
like my family is complete exactly
especially when they have both genders
they also feel that way yeah yeah yeah
yeah either way I'm super happy for her
yeah same but I feel like we could in
another couple months from now like it
could just be another be another one and
I would be super stoked for her too yeah
either way either way yeah our next
story Beyonce premiered her film
Renaissance in the US this weekend a lot
of stars showing up and showing out and
she looked beautiful in a silver
Platinum Versace gown so um the stars
came out for uh Beyonce's Premiere isere
lizo janal mon um all attended the
premiere Taylor Swift was notably absent
you know Beyonce went to her premiere
but Taylor has shows and she's still
like grieving the loss of her fans so I
don't think she was going to be rocking
the carpet or rocking the stage at
Arrowhead for that matter for sure was
Kim there no oh people were like hoping
that maybe they would like see each
other there and by people I mean Li Liz
P Woods oh she thought Kim might be
there yeah yeah I guess she really could
have been there yeah but she wasn't she
wasn't um so when does the movie come
out like when can we see it I guess that
means like when there's a Premiere then
it's like a few days later yeah okay
cool there's a lot of this is like movie
season also Taylor announced today that
on December 13th Eros tour will be
available on demand oh good like that's
really what I'm looking for because I
don't know the last time that like I've
like been to the movie scen A like to
the theater scen a movie but I love
watching movies so and then also there's
the new movie wish okay the new Disney
movie there's Napoleon which I've heard
was God awful really and the front to
Napoleon
darn yeah the reviews were not good I
don't even know if I will see
it because there's another movie a
scorey one also flowers flower Moon yeah
and there was one more that we were just
talking about I think on the on the
patreon oh um Hunger Games prequel oh uh
it sounds good it does yeah it's
President Snow Arin story you know that
doesn't mean you see Hunger Games I saw
one when y'all forced me into the movie
theater to watch it like 10 years ago
but I have like I I understand the
concept but it's not like something I'm
a part of you never watched like the
whole series no what do you think about
Twilight you're such a contrarian it's
not that I'm contrarian these are just
like not things that I enjoy watching
like vampires and wolves you know that's
like not my vibe what's your Vibe like
CIA yes yeah yes FBI CIA so do you like
movies like like Zero Dark 30 is that
like your favorite movie it's not my
favorite I honestly have never seen it
but I feel like I would like it never se
you haven't seen it no no okay what
about like Saving Private Ryan or um
yeah no I've seen that it's not my
favorite but I've seen it Jarhead not
seen it I haven't seen it either I'm
just naming military movies yeah no like
CIA FBI like doesn't necessarily mean
military like the types of movies that I
love are like the oceans movies Italian
job like heisty Vibes is really like my
favorite type of movie do you like the
most recent oceans movies with the
ladies I did very entertaining what's
not to like yeah yeah and I just love
when they like you know trick you yeah
like now you see me like I love movies
like that you know so funny do you like
Kingsmen love obsess obsess Kingsmen
could Heal the World everyone loves that
movie AG there was one really bad one
with Julianne Moore and it was still
good it wasn't even bad yeah it wasn't
bad it's always on TV the Golden Circle
yeah no I love they just had another one
the king's man which is like the prequel
it's out I feel like a Kingsman movie
doesn't come out without Claud and I
knowing about it no it's it's been out
for like a few years you must have seen
it then Kingsman
movie when did it come out 2021 wait the
Kings man Stanley Tui that's confusing
just cu the other guy looks like Stanley
chuchi but yeah you're
right we have to tell Claudia she loves
Kingsman too I love like and and by the
way like I love I love a lot of movies
but I'm not really into like the sci-fi
e squally e like Hunger Games Twilight
and like I'll watch them if you're all
watching them together it's just like
not something I seek out okay yeah got
it like Bella Edward like they just
don't really do it for me but um she's
wrong for that she's Team Jacob aren't
you do you even know what that means
yeah the werewolf are you Team Jacob no
let the record state I'm team nobody oh
I'll be team reneesme you guys used to
say that Kayla was reneesme like when
she was born yeah why did we say that
because she was growing
quickly that's like the thing about
renez oh no cuz she would look at you I
guess all babies do this now that I've
met other babies that like they look at
you like they're showing you like renz's
you know uh her superpower which is like
they show you all the memories but she
like has to stare at you and focus and
that's what she used to do that's so fun
you guys used to just say stuff like
that and I'll accept it yeah sure it's a
compliment yeah but I don't you know it
didn't really like fely understood what
it meant yeah no I think it's cuz she
was showing us all her memories with us
cute yeah it was a cute thing we were
saying you missed it um are you ready
for our next Story another cute thing
that you might have missed if I didn't
bring it to your attention please share
black pink brings the girl group Glam to
the Buckingham Palace State banquet with
the royal family you guys I'm obsessed
and I'm taking this moment to bring up a
royal family story it's been so long
educate us educate you because I posted
to my Instagram story black pink met
King Charles like I'm not okay and
Olivia's like who are these people I was
like it's black pink like you don't know
black pink in your air like you don't
know their songs are how would I know
like where would I hear it their songs
like are hold on let me you know I'm
going to play their most popular song CU
I do think like Tik Tok music no Olivia
I'm not on Tik Tok no I know that's why
I'm confused as to like where would I
hear this like it's not on series on the
highway not interested watch did you
ever watch um
to all the boys those movies um the
movies isn't it oh no that's a summer I
turn pretty I watched the first one oh
this one kill this love this is probably
their most popular
[Music]
song do you know this song No but I like
it it's good
right
I'm telling you li okay I'm into it no I
I never had I want to see you in the
Wagoner blasting black pig by the way
next time you see me that's what I'll be
doing it's such a good song but anyways
they so they are like such a big K-pop
girl group they like did Coachella and
they're so talented they also have a
documentary on Netflix if you want to
learn more about honestly love a
documentary so yeah so they turned heads
in glamorous gowns they looked beautiful
at the Buckingham Palace State banquet
on Tuesday with South Korean artists
attending in support of the president
and first lady before the group was made
honorary members of the order of the
British Empire the K-Pop singers looked
Regal for Tuesday night's banquet with
each member bringing her own style to
the glittering banquet which was also
attended by King Charles Cavalier
Spaniel III Queen Camila The Prince and
Princess of
Wales Kon William The Duchess of
Edinburgh and The Duchess of gluster
that's my stab at pronouncing that cor I
watched part one of the crown this
weekend actually and really good I mean
it it's I just like I didn't want to
watch it because it was only part one
and part two comes out I think on like
December 14th but um I just felt like I
had to and it was you know I don't want
to give it away but I guess I'm not
because it's based on real but it's like
you know the Diana story yeah which we
know we know that it's about Diana yeah
yeah yeah um and I think they do a
masterful job as always so um I love it
and I'm excited for part two I'm waiting
for part two in order to start part one
plus I so much I have so much reading to
do I actually don't even have time to
watch it right now and we it's a good
thing to watch with the whole family
over the holidays cuz I think everybody
likes that okay so you're saying you're
going to watch part one again is that
okay you said it was masterful I don't
like to watch things twice that's like
I'm really I'm really not into that like
I find it super annoying thing it's a
new thing like it in like binge era
where it's like growing up when we like
something we watched it over and over
over and over again and now like you
watch these shows or movies once and
that's it that's it maybe for kids like
they still watch those same movies over
again but like maybe when you're kid
it's just different I think it's a
different personality types like if
you're the type of person that will like
watch friends every night and like
rewatch the same episodes over and over
like I'm not well if you're the type of
person that watches friends period right
like or the office like I just don't
that's not like I will not turn on
something I've seen already and like
watch it if I need to like mindlessly
watch like I'll always seek out
something new I would probably waste all
the time that I have seeking out
watching something new just watching
trailers and then you go to sleep my
favorite thing to do is watch trailers I
love it well I know that the crown is
ending soon so we won't get up to um you
know an episode with black pink meeting
King Charles darn and that's a loss for
everyone because I would love to know
what happened at this dinner um I
imagine it was wonderful and I'm sure it
was absolutely fabulous I can't wait to
dive into them how amazing they look wow
yeah the video of that meeting King
Charles was so cute that was just like
not on my bingo card for things I was
waiting for to happen or you know even
thought about but it was something that
I needed yeah who who would you love to
see um King Charles Cavalier meet next
ooh it's always fun like to see like
forever who meets the Royals I don't
know who he has me he's you know been
around a while he's probably met a lot
of people but as like who do I want to
see like get invited to a state dinner
great
question think about
it like Elon has he been I'm sure
they've met I'm sure they've met yeah
but has he been like an official guest
thought going to be like Luke Colmes you
know luk comes yes L I would love to see
Nicole
coms 100% that's what I'm I'm waiting
for and then he can perform for all of
them and W that's what they need yeah
they like to drink beer like it seems
like you know similar Vibes yeah cuz
they're like really into like pints you
know in Britain pints and Pints yeah
and yeah pints never broke my something
PS never broke my heart that's beautiful
Olivia thank you thank you um yeah no
that I would I'm here for King Charles
ex Luke Holmes 100% put it on my 2024
vision board okay do you have a do you
do those things yeah I I just I needed
to make sure I was I have I don't have a
vision board I have a planner and I feel
like that but like in the beginning of
your planner do you write here are all
my goals for 2024 and then look look
back at them and say wow look how much I
didn't do no okay and honestly like I'm
the type of person who who I like I'm
the opposite of a manifestor cuz I feel
like if you speak it like it doesn't
happen yeah yeah yeah I totally agree
with that so it would be interesting to
see what my goals are but I don't have
like such actionable goals like that
yeah you just like want to live your
life my goals are Vibes you know totally
it's about the
energy it's about the exchange of
energy do you have a planner no have a
Google Calendar my okay it works fine my
Google Calendar on my phone and my
computer are never syned oh that's a u
problem I think it's a tech problem also
a u problem it's the tech fix your Tech
no but like the tech should fix itself
honestly like what else are they
doing you know sure they're so busy in
your business okay sync up my calendars
then you want my business fine how many
calendars do you have just like I just
use my calendar on my phone and sometime
like when I'm on my phone I need to make
a note of like an event I put it on my
phone and then when my on my computer
calendar it's not there wrong I know
what you're doing you're not like coding
it to the right email no exactly I'm not
coding it there's another there's no no
not by that I mean like encoding like
there's another area there where it says
calendar and you need to click that and
put it to the like your email I I'll
show you I'll show you okay or I just
get a physical planner where I write
down everything I know but like you're
you're doing that as art you're not
doing that for like legitimate
scheduling no legitimate scheduling I
need to be able to see my week okay
visualize it how's your week looking
busy busy it's a busy time of year I'm
busy till the end of the year really
like every day I've have like multiple
things I know and the weekends work
obligations yeah no I know and in the
weekends yeah everyone's just like
having a birthday but it's nice it's
nice like the how this year like this
time of year gets so booked and busy but
then like what's going to happen in
January it's depressing really no I feel
like there's still stuff in J always
stuff I feel like March is depressing
that's the month of depression no cuz
then it like becomes like spring Breaky
Passover I don't know when Passover is
this year but like then it's that Vibe
there's always something going on
yeah well it's not the state dinner that
I'm invited to but um yeah you could
have said you you and Claudia oh me not
Claudia she can stay home me I want to
go bring me they should do a podcasting
Symposium and that's never going to
happen that's on my vision board okay
okay okay I'm going to m f it a
podcasting Symposium at Buckingham
Palace podcon
2024 at the palace us and smartless
hobnobbing with the Royals there it
is now Dre now it's going to come true
dream on are you ready for our next
story I sure am but I have to let you
know it's a story brought to you by
Legacy box you guys do not skip over
this s because it's this time of year
Olivia is sipping my coffee but I'm so
hyped up on Legacy box I'm I'm I'm okay
with it so Legacy box is the perfect
gift always but especially this time of
year you've heard us talk about talk
about Legacy box all year long but now
is the time to take advantage of their
best sale of the Year during their cyber
week event Legacy box is the most
meaningful gift you can give this
holiday season to family or even
yourself it's simple safe and has been
trusted by millions and for limited time
you can preserve your tapes film reels
and photos for as low as $27 saving you
hundreds so Legacy box if you don't know
what it is it's a simple and safe way to
digitize your Treasured Memories
videotapes film reels photos Legacy box
sends you an empty box you put any of
those things that you have you know we
have a closet full of old videotapes
that we don't have the apparatus to
watch anymore so we put everything in a
box sent it off to Legacy box they
digitize it send it back to you and then
we were able to watch all of these old
Home Videos we were such hams growing up
that like someone needs to watch these
videos like if young us knew that these
tapes were just sitting in a closet they
would be so bum but then we finally got
them back it's so funny to see how like
we're so changed and older but we're the
same our personalities are the exact
same and Legacy box is the gift that
keeps on giving this holiday season it
is what you want to give if you have a
secret Santa like honestly it could work
for anyone in your family Legacy box
100% Hur hurry because Legacy box best
sale of the Year won't last long visit
legacybox.com toast for an unreal 65%
off during the Legacy box cyber week
event with limited quantities ready to
ship this deal will go fast shop Legacy
box lowest price of the year now at
legacybox.com toast buy your legacy box
today send it in when you're ready
legacybox.com
toast now today's episode is also
brought to you by Skylight frames
another amazing meaningful gift this
holiday season that your loved ones will
actually use and enjoy so again it's
hard to get creative with gifts you want
to do something personal but also pretty
for the home Skylight frames is that
gift basically it's a digital frame you
send it to whomever and then you can or
they but it's fun when you program what
pictures are going to populate in the
frame you could pick one amazing photo
you could switch it out as often as you
want you could do something new every
day you could even send like if your
loved one lives across the country you
could send a new photo every day of your
kid or your dog and like they get to
kind of keep up with them through the
Skylight frame it's like a physical
embodiment of them not just looking at
everything on your phone which is so so
nice so it's great to gift to family and
friends with young children or a new
baby great for a grandparent a sibling I
know Claudia loves hers and I love mine
she's always sending me new pictures of
do I'm always sending her new pictures
of the boys it's so so beautiful and
obviously finding the perfect gift for
family members can be very very hard
Skylight frames is solving that as a
special limited time offer for our
listeners get $15 off your purchase of a
skylight frame when you go to
skylightframe.com
toast to get $15 off your purchase of a
skylight frame just go Skylight frame
fr.com toast that's s y l i g HT f r a m
e.com
toast the best gift really so many great
gift options in today's sponsors thank
you to our sponsors and Skylight frame
is just like a gorgeous wonderful gift
for an in-law anyone I could wax I could
go on and on about I I can't think of a
person who would be a bad recipient of
the Skylight frame no also a lot of moms
use a skylight frame as a shared Google
Calendar um on their kitchen counter
like so that way the calendar comes up
and then you can see like all the
activities of the week someone was
literally just talking to me about
Skylight last week at a breakfast that I
was that of how it like changed their
life mom hack mom hack okay next story
um two names didn't expect to see in a
same sentence this weekend but Dave
pornoy is denying seeing Raquel Levis in
Illinois despite rumors so there was a
rumor going around that Dave poroi and
Rachel Rael Levis from Banner pump rolls
were spotted in the same small town in
Illinois on the same day just before his
ex-girlfriend hinted at her split from
Dave so two things one Dave and his
girlfriend broke up uh his ex announced
it this weekend and then it was rumored
that he was spotted with Raquel which
prompted Dave to post a really mean
nasty statement about her saying quote I
can confirm I've never met that trash
bag in my life and it's wildly insulting
to even be mentioned in the same
sentence as her obviously very mean but
can I tell you what my problem with the
story is so Dave and Rachel again I
don't watch better pump rolles that's
her name yeah well her name was it's
confusing but I think now she like
chooses to go by Rachel so apparently
they were spotted in the same town in
Illinois a month ago and like no one
decided to write anything then do you
know what I mean so like there seems
like they were making a story up once
like Dave's now ex-girlfriend said that
they broke up do you know what I mean
like why a month ago wasn't it like oh
Dave and this girl spotted in the same
do you know what I mean yeah
that is interesting though it's kind of
like a a small town they say they don't
get a lot of celebrities and they were
both there on the same day but I don't
think that means that they were hooking
up he said that he was there to review
Uncle Jerry's Pizza Company and I
believe that honestly because that's
what he does and he he said spacular got
8.3 she was at a coffee place and
stopped to take some selfies I don't
know what she's doing there she doesn't
really give she's not super like
forthcoming she's not really on social
media anymore as far as they've seen you
know it's defin really mean but the one
thing I will say that I do appreciate
about Dave is like if there's somebody
asking for a comment from him like not
only is he going to make the comment
he's going to show you the exact comment
he made and make make the whole thing
even bigger because of his comment right
right yeah well okay so they're not
together I didn't think that they were I
didn't think that it didn't make sense
to doesn't make sense 100% plus one
equals S I actually liked Dave with his
girlfriend I know I think people are
upset that they broke up yeah I don't
like know them or anything about but
they seem to like be happy together yeah
and they were together for a while and
he's kind of been um you know she tamed
him in a sense and she stood by him like
when he was going through it too yeah so
who knows what happened there I think
that was also people trying to like make
sense of the two of them splitting up
being like oh cuz he cheated on her with
Rachel right which is obviously not true
I don't think so yeah so yeah just
wanted I hope that you'll as I always
say find your happiness yeah our fifth
and final story is some interesting
Shipping News that I think people should
know
UPS UPS and FedEx are no longer the
largest delivery companies in the us
both UPS and FedEx have been eclipsed as
the largest courier companies in the US
by Amazon which delivered more packages
to US homes in recent years than both
delivery Giants Amazon surpassed UPS in
parcel volume in 200 22 that's weird to
say it like
that cuz we say 2022
sounds fine to me 2022 yeah and we're in
2023 yeah I guess I don't know I just
like it was feeling off to I was reading
on autopilot and it just sounded weird
um anyways Amazon's bigger than UPS and
FedEx that's the tea That's
crazy yeah so like Jeff Bezos is because
Amazon is also only delivering stuff
from Amazon of course so and like ups
inetics are delivering from like
everywhere else in the planet yeah yeah
so Jeff Bezos is a shipping magnate yeah
that's why Amazon just has like such a
choke hold on everyone and everything
you know I mean the thing is like I know
everyone likes to rail on Amazon and
sometimes I go out of my way to like not
get something on Amazon or you even
found with kids clothes like I don't
love the quality from of course it would
be easiest to buy from Amazon so I shop
you know little mom and pop this and
that takes forever I ordered new pajamas
for the boys two weeks ago and they're
still not here if I got them from Amazon
they would have been here I mean I'm
glad that I didn't because like like I
said the quality is not great but like
it makes you appreciate Amazon yeah but
sometimes you need stuff that the
quality is not great and that's what
Amazon is perfect for and Amazon's
perfect for everything kitchen every but
like I'm so accustomed I need something
I get it the next day or two days later
like waiting 2 weeks for a package now
was like unheard of I know I know and
then they're giving it to Amazon they're
giving because I'm like actually I love
this one place so much I will continue
to wait um but it's with all kids
clothes like not to call out a million
Brands but like every time I buy it
takes so long I know you got to shop on
unless I shop from um like big box like
a Nordstrom or something like that H&M
Gap those ones H&M takes forever they
came in a few days still it's not Amazon
yeah but where I ordered their PJs from
it's going on two weeks I placed an
order on H&M n um Char's a new size now
a little while ago literally and they
were like sorry that your order delayed
like here's 15% off your next order it
was 2 weeks late and also half the order
wasn't mine where was it from from H&M
oh I yeah it was big yikes and like I
appreciated that they knew it was
delayed and they gave me 15% off but I
called them I'm like I don't know how to
return this because like I don't have a
return for it so it's just going back to
you and that's the thing returns returns
is no no thank you yeah and Amazon does
make returns so easy yeah they do but I
still don't I I'll figure out a way to
use it implemented in my life before I
return unless it's like a really big
purchase that like I bought knowing I
might have to return it yeah yeah yeah
or like the size is really wrong but I
hate returning I mean I hate returning
too know who makes Returns the easiest
revolve oh do they oh my gosh the
easiest yeah that's so great yeah and
that's why they have a successful
business yeah take a page yeah yeah but
you know I think they're one of those
ones that it's like if you return more
than you buy like if you become oh
you're blacklisted no not blacklisted
but like you you don't have those same
privileges anymore like if you become
more honestly appreciate that yeah no
for sure like it's it's a nice per they
still let you buy it's a nice perk don't
take advantage somebody we knew got in
trouble with Amazon for doing that yeah
yeah he
did do people know that story no I don't
think so okay another day another story
for another day so those were the fast
five stories I feel as though you needed
to know them and I hope everyone had a
great weekend has a great kind of a
little unhinged this episode more so
than our usual more so than we're
usually pretty by the book but I agree
it went a little off the rails which I
enjoy me too I enjoyed myself very much
here I enjoyed myself too me too and
it's a it's the greatest time of year
you guys so I don't know if you have
realized that like let's acknowledge the
space that we're in it's the holidays
the lights are up The Vibes are vibing
the cheermeister is here let's enjoy
yeah I love this time of year it's my
favorite it's it's really wonderful so
enjoy it and we will see you tomorrow is
the season hopefully Claudia will be
back tomorrow with good news on our boy
do prayers up for do strong and thank
you Olivia for being here thank you for
having me and thank you Claudia for
letting me sit in your seat I appreciate
you and I'm thinking of you and thank
you all for listening to our show the
best show ever that should be invited to
Buckingham Palace for a podcasting
Symposium we will see you tomorrow make
sure to like subscribe follow you can
follow Olivia on Instagram yeah follow
me at Olivia ashre great content great
stuff you could always follow me on
Instagram that's always been an option
at Jackie ashr and we will see you
tomorrow how people listen to this
podcast and not follow you I think that
people most of the people who listen to
the podcast follow me but I don't know I
feel like maybe they just listen as a
they enjoy like the podcast maybe they
don't follow that many like influencers
on the day to day that's fair 100% you
know I feel like there are some shows
where I follow the show and it's like I
don't follow the host necessarily yeah
that's fair so let's change that for you
if you're one of those people um and
have a wonderful blessed day love love
you bye